What number sets does the
number 8 belong to?
Now before even answering that
question, let's just think
about the different number
sets there are.
There are the real numbers.
And these are, literally, all
of the numbers we've been
dealing with to date.
When we go to more advanced
topics, you'll learn that
there are such things as
imaginary and complex numbers.
Or at least in the mathematical
sense they exist.
But for now, real numbers are
essentially everything that we
know of on the number line.
So if I were to draw the number
line right here, a real
number can be represented as any
point on this number line.
Or it's the set of all of the
points on this number line if
you just keep going in the
positive direction and you
just keep going in the
negative direction.
It's all of these point.
And it includes points, it
includes numbers like pi,
where their decimal
representations, 3.14159, it
just keeps repeating
on and on and on.
It cannot be represented as a
fraction or as a rational
expression.
It just is this decimal
expansion that goes on and on
and on and on.
Square root of 2 is another
one that is also a real.
But everything else
is also real.
So real is kind of the broadest
set of numbers we've
been dealing with.
Now if we want to be a little
bit more restrictive, we get
to rational numbers.
And the best way to think about
rational, there's two
ways to think about it.
These are numbers that can be
expressed as-- you could say
as a rational expression
or as a fraction.
So for example, negative 1 is
a rational number because
negative 1 could be written
as negative 1/1.
0 is a rational number.
It can be expressed as
0 over anything.
Could be 0/10.
It doesn't have to be.
2 is a rational number.
1/2 is a rational number.
All of these are rational
numbers.
What aren't rational numbers are
numbers like square root
of 2 or 3.14 or pi or e, these
numbers that cannot be
represented as a fraction.
So you can imagine that the
rational numbers, it's kind of
like the set of real numbers.
Maybe I'll write it like this.
It's the set of real numbers
minus-- if you were to take
out irrational numbers.
And these are like-- so for
example, we have things like
pi, e, these are
actual numbers.
You know, 3.1415, e is
between 2 and 3.
Square root of 2.
We can go on and on and on.
There's an infinite number
of irrational numbers.
So it's a little abstract.
But anything that can be
represented as a fraction, you
definitely know is rational.
Now, if we want to get a little
bit more restrictive
than that, if we just want to
deal with the numbers that
aren't fractions in the
traditional sense.
That are, I guess we could use
the word whole numbers,
although we want to be careful
with that word because that
could also be considered
a number set.
If we're thinking about just
the 4, the 3, the 2, all of
the kind of-- I guess
whole numbers.
Then we're talking about
the integers.
We could just go from the
negative direction, maybe
negative 2, negative
1, then 0.
Then we get 1, 2, 3.
I think you get the idea.
It's all of the positive and
negative whole numbers and it
includes 0.
So if you were to do the
integers on this line, it
would be everything that
I'm doing in orange.
Now, there's two other sets that
are subsets of integers
depending on the interpretation
you look at.
So sometimes you'll hear people
say, whole numbers.
And this is a bit of an
ambiguous statement.
Because sometimes when people
say whole numbers, they're
referring to integers.
Sometimes when they're referring
to whole numbers,
they're referring to
non-negative integers.
So 0, 1, 2, 3.
Sometimes they're referring
to just positive integers.
So 1, 2, 3, so on
and so forth.
So this is a little
bit ambiguous.
I've seen it used in all of
those different ways.
But if someone says a whole
number, I generally think of
non-negative numbers.
It's ambiguous, but for our
purposes, let's think of it as
0, 1, 2, so on and so forth.
Now the last one to consider
is natural numbers.
And once again, this one
is also ambiguous.
And the reason why it's called
natural numbers is these are
numbers that you would actually
encounter if you were
to either try to order
things or actually
count things in nature.
So this is also ambiguous.
But it definitely excludes
negative numbers.
And so if it definitely excludes
negative numbers,
you're like, why is
it ambiguous?
Well, it's ambiguous whether
it includes 0.
So sometimes 0 is natural.
So 0 may or may not be natural,
depending on the context.
Now, let's answer our
actual question.
What number sets does
8 belong to?
Well, 8 definitely belongs
to the real numbers.
It is on the number line.
It is definitely a
rational number.
We can express it as 8/1, or
16/2, or even negative 8 over
negative 1.
I mean you could actually have
an infinite number of ways to
express it as a fraction.
So it's definitely a
rational number.
It's definitely an integer.
It's a whole number.
It is a whole number.
I mean we're ambiguous what to
include in whole numbers, but
positive 8 is unambiguously
a whole number.
It's definitely included.
And it's unambiguously
a natural number.
If I go out and count trees,
I can count 8 trees.
So it is a positive.
If the number was 0, I'd be
like, well, depending on who
you talk to it might be
a natural number.
But 8 definitely is
So it's a part of all of
these number sets.